[Music]
americans held hostage behind enemy
lines day 109
well everybody else seems to have turned
the page we refused to on this program
109 days counting and tonight the
taliban along with the rest of america's
enemies they are now taking advantage of
your president joe biden's obvious
weakness on the world stage coming up
former secretary of state mike pompeo
will join us with the very latest out of
russia china the middle east afghanistan
and later stacey abrams thinks that
she's running for re-election as the
rightful governor of georgia will have
full coverage of the midterm elections
that is straight ahead alec baldwin now
speaking out after allegedly killing a
person on the set of a movie now the far
left actor is now claiming he never
pulled the trigger before accidentally
shooting two people on a movie set
well if he didn't pull the trigger who
did
but first we begin with an important
christmas message yes from president joe
biden today he proudly announced that he
takes no responsibility at all
whatsoever for the supply chain crisis
and according to joe if your kid's
presence do not arrive in time for
christmas you better take it up with
santa claus take a look
now i can't promise that every person
will get every gift they want on time
only santa claus can keep that promise
but they're items every year that sell
out that are hard to find
some of you moms and dads may remember
cabbage packed kids back in the 80s or
beanie babies in the 90s or other toys
that have run out at christmas time in
past years when there was no supply
chain problem
all right joe wants you to think the
supply chain crisis is a myth that it's
santa claus's fault according to him the
empty shelves that you see right here
are not empty now if your presence don't
arrive in time you're to blame well of
course
santa and if you can't blame him why not
blame donald trump i guess everybody's
to blame but him gen saki calling it the
tragedy of the delayed treadmill
according to mayor pede you should have
done your christmas shopping before
halloween
if not oh well so sad too bad your kids
will be crying for christmas not liking
santa claus and they won't be happy you
might remember some of these moments
and
this administration guarantee
that holiday packages will arrive on
time
we are not the postal service or ups or
fedex uh we cannot guarantee i think
there's always been two kinds of
christmas shoppers there's the ones who
have all their list completed by
halloween and then there's people like
me who show up at the mall on christmas
eve if you're in that ladder bucket
obviously there's going to be more
challenges people couldn't get
dishwashers and
furniture and treadmills delivered on
time not to mention all sorts of other
things so why is the tragedy of the
short the treadmill that's delayed
fundamentally supply chains and
logistics are run by the private sector
you know people say to me will christmas
gifts be delivered to which i say call
fedex you know that that isn't what the
government does
blame the postal service ups fedex as
you can see the buck does not stop with
joe or anybody in the white house in
fact chief of staff ron claim he
actually thinks this economy is doing
great now today in a tweet that should
be deeply concerning to every american
claine is writing quote stronger covert
measures produce stronger economic
outcomes oh we need more draconian
covert measures that's the answer to a
to a healthy economy of course the
opposite is true and as you can see the
biden administration takes
responsibility for nothing including the
ongoing pandemic that biden promised he
would shut down now this new omicron
variant sadly it is now officially here
confirmed in the u.s thankfully this new
strain of covet according to early
reports causes mild symptoms although it
may be more contagious and while i
always encourage everyone to take the
pandemic seriously there is as of today
no reason to panic check with your
doctor but that didn't stop joe biden
from banning travel from a variety of
african countries but when donald trump
banned travel from china where the virus
originated from biden called him
hysterical xenophobic and a fear-monger
and of course suggested he's racist
apparently now it's okay because
president joe uh and dr fauci approve
but today even fauci could not explain
the african ban take a look
unjustified would justify imposing a
travel ban on countries that have zero
case of the omicron
variant
you know
that's a very good question an important
question and and we did struggle with
that but we wanted to see if we could
bide time temporarily so i do hope that
this gets sorted out and lifted before
it has any significant impact on your
country
i still want to know why the nih gave
money to the eco alliance that
according to the nih was involved in
gain of function research at the wuhan
virology lab on bat coronaviruses anyway
to recap according to biden trump was a
racist for banning travel from china
where the outbreak started perfectly
okay for him to ban travel from certain
african countries where the omicron
variant isn't even really present really
joe now of course throughout this entire
pandemic there's one thing we can always
count on and that is the great flip-flop
dr fauci uh who's in love with his
newfound celebrity status his 15 minutes
have been over a long long time ago he
should be fired and like all good
celebrities fauci recently spent some
quality time with barack obama during an
event that was open to the press and of
course today fauci was more than happy
to spend a long time at the white house
press briefing speculating about
anything and everything including new
coven 19 testing requirements but let
not your hearts be troubled because if
you're an illegal immigrant and you
unlawfully you know break the laws don't
respect our borders our sovereignty
these new rules won't apply to you
that doesn't make sense does it
but
nothing he says makes sense this is the
guy that said in march of 2020 on 16
minutes oh that mask isn't going to work
that mask you're not going to work take
a look
as you advise the president about the
possibility of new testing requirements
for people coming into this country does
that include
everybody
the answer is yes because you know that
the new uh
the new uh regulation if you want to
call it that is that anybody and
everybody who's coming into the country
needs to get a test within 24 hours of
getting on the plane to come here well
what about people who don't take a plane
and just these border crossers coming in
in huge numbers
that's a different issue for example
when you're talking we still have title
42 with regard to protection at the
border so there are protections at the
border that you don't have the
capability as you know of somebody
getting on a plane getting checked
looking at a passport we don't have that
there but we can get some degree of
mitigation there you go that's right
pouchy and biden more than happy to ban
travel from africa but if you enter this
country illegally or you just waltz
right through and you get preferential
treatment you get no testing because jan
saki says you're not going to be here
very long and then you don't need a
covert vaccine mandate because uh oh
you're not going to be here very long
uh anyway as we continue it's no wonder
that more americans have died under
biden's watch from 2021
and from kova 19 in 2021 and under
trump's watch in 2020 peter ducey asked
gen saki about this and saki got very
very angry take a look
in 2020 when roughly 220 000 americans
had already died of covet joe biden said
about trump anyone who is responsible
for that many deaths should not remain
as president of the united states of
america is that still the standard now
that more americans have died under
president biden than president trump
well i think the fundamental question
here is what are you doing to save lives
and protect people and the former
president was suggesting people inject
bleach he apparently reportedly didn't
even share with people he was going to
interact with that he had tested
positive for kovitt himself
he continued to provide a forum for
misinformation which probably led to
people not getting not taking steps
forward to get to protect themselves to
wear a mask to eventually get vaccinated
this president has made the vaccine
widely available he's relied on the
health uh the advice of his health and
medical experts
we all know jen sake biden and voucher
all liars and of course they love to
smear president trump but really what
else can she do joe biden is a disaster
his policies are terrible his brain is
barely functioning america is now facing
several major crises he has caused
everyone and all of them have been
preventable now republicans independents
democrats are desperately looking for a
better way forward